Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, so there’s
this brand new show my friends at Geek and
Sundry are doing that I’m really excited
about.
So I’m going to be doing a few bonus videos
for it.
It’s called Arcade Arms and they’re going
to be forging real life versions of famous
video game weapons and doing some cool stuff
with them.
Mostly smashing things, I think their permit
for human testing is still pending.
So this video is going to be a breakdown of
some of the weapons they’re going to be
using and when they’re going to start posting
episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
I’ll have links for the show down in the
description.
So the show is actually going to be hosted
by Nika Harper.
If you haven’t seen her before she’s been
doing a lot of stuff with Geek and Sundry
for the past couple of years like Wordplay.
She also did a League of Legends show on their
official channel called Summoner Showcase.
I think she’s really good.
I really like her enthusiasm for breaking
stuff with giant weapons.
Because all these weapons are based on really
big video games they also did a bunch of cool
interviews with the people that actually made
the games.
So like for instance, in the first episode
they have the Lead Loremaster for Elder Scrolls
on talk about the story behind the weapon
they make in that video.
So really a big part of all this is doing
the lore for each of the weapons, then actually
making them in real life.
They went all the way to Canada to find the
person to make their first one.
Here are the top 5 things I’m most excited
about.
Number 5 - learning about how they make each
of the weapons.
The smiths that they picked to make everything
talk a lot about the practical aspects of
the weapons and why they have specific features.
Number 4 - The locations.
They actually had to travel a lot to shoot
the show.
Most of the people that make the weapons are
specialists and live all over the place.
They had to go to Canada for the first episode.
Number 3 - The lore behind the weapons.
If you’ve seen some of my other videos you
know I like to research mythology a lot.
They talk to a lot of the people at each of
the game companies about the stories behind
the weapons.
It’s like learning about Game of Thrones
from George RR Martin.
Number 2 - Cool behind the scenes info about
each of the games.
In addition to talking about the weapons in
the games, they get a lot of cool behind the
scenes details about why the game designers
made certain story choices.
You’d be surprised at the amount of time
developers devote to the story aspects of
games.
and Number 1 - Watching them actually use
the weapons.
They went to a lot of LARP societies to learn
about how say a giant mace would be used in
a real battle and why you’d choose that
weapon instead of say, a sword.
They take it one step further too and smash
the hell out of stuff.
The mace they made is like 35 pounds, which
is more than enough to crush someone’s skull
even if they’re wearing plate armor.
So here’s what the episodes are going to
be, they’re all going to post on Geek And
Sundry’s main channel once every two weeks.
The first one will be Molag Bal’s Mace from
Elder Scrolls Online.
That will air next week.
May 13th.
Then two weeks after that will be the Gael
Bolg from Final Fantasy Realm Reborn and the
third one will be Zelda’s Hero Bow from
Legend Of Zelda.
That will air June 10th.
So remember new episodes every two weeks.
For my bonus videos I’m going to talk a
little bit about the characters and the lore
behind the mythology behind the weapons and
the games.
So let’s talk some Elder Scrolls Online.
In case you haven’t been playing the beta,
Elder Scrolls Online is a brand new MMO based
on Bethesda’s Elder Scrolls mythology like
Skyrim.
So think Skyrim MMO.
It’s been out on PC since April but it’s
coming to Xbox One and PS4 later this year
if you’re a console gamer.
The Weapon they’re doing for the first Episode
belongs to Molag Bal, so let’s break him
down.
He’s one of the sixteen daedric prince end
bosses in the Skyrim Dragonborn DLC.
He was appeared in Oblivion.
But for the purposes of this video we’ll
just stick to The mmo.
The Daedric Princes are like the most powerful
of the Gods and each of them has their own
separate plane of existence.
In the game all of them are associated with
super weapons you can obtain, like the mace.
They’re like raid quality items with mega
bonuses.
Molag is mostly like a harvester of souls.
Part of the quest you have to complete to
get his mace involves convincing someone to
sacrifice their soul to him.
So it’s one of those alignment quests that
takes you down a much darker road.
But if you like playing evil characters it’s
a lot of fun.
Quick side note.
One of the first games that gave you a lot
of freedom with your alignment and quest choices
was the first Knights of The Old Republic.
Playing Revan as evil always led to way better
cut scenes.
Because the character is part of the new MMO
they got Malcolm McDowell to do the voice.
Which is really freaking awesome.
He plays some of the best evil video game
characters.
The Mace itself has a lot of vampiric bonuses
and you can upgrade it, but you need to max
out blacksmithing to do it.
The funny thing about equipping it is that
it’s so big it takes up most of the screen.
So it’s just really hard to see what’s
going on when you’re playing.
Molag Bal is the main villain of the MMO,
future expansions will probably add in lore
from the other Daedric princes.
The interesting thing about the story of the
MMO is that it incorporates player resurrection
as part of the conceit of the game.
Molag Bal has basically stolen your soul so
you keep getting resurrected.
As you play through the game you try to get
it back.
I guess so you can finally die.
There are three playable factions right now
and nine different races.
So there’s a little more choice for people
who are getting burnt out on Warcraft.
Plus no matter which class you choose, DPS,
Melee or Caster you can still tweak for armor
and weapon skills.
So you can be a caster that wears plate.
The only bummer is that because of the era
the game takes place in, there aren’t any
dragons.
But they’ll probably be incorporated in
a future expansion.
So I’ll be doing a couple more bonus videos
for each of the weapons and games they do.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And links for the actual show are in the description.
The first episode premieres next week on Tuesday
on Geek and Sundry’s youtube channel.
If there’s a special weapon you think they
should do just leave suggestions in the comments.
And if you want to see me do more video game
lore vids let me know.
I might move some of those to my bonus gaming
channel just because that’s where all my
gameplay is going.
Right now click here for their first video
and click here for my Final Fantasy Bonus
Video.
I’ll add the annotation after I post it.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow!